proprio lui quello che fai video inizia
con bella tutti ragazzi e tutto il resto
ciao a tutti ragazzi su youtube e rose
la fp sodi offri perché effettiva no
quattromiglia manco puntate eravamo
rimasti che più di pai ha trovato un
malvivente che voleva fotterci follower
facendo pubblicità un gioco di merda e
l'altra non dimenticherei filippetti
aspetta in questo quartiere ma come cioè
più di fi che sta tenendo un criminale
fermo da un giorno e mezzo io che eccolo
qua lo zio dove senti cyber war è una
pizza da quattro fette del cazzo vuol
dire che li fai visto che fanno le cose
ei sei arrivato mai ha trovato
rivenditori quando un po l'ha beccato
con le mani nel sacco per a facili con
gigi macarons che si desse messi insieme
sono meno affidabili di un orco in un
ascensore va bene volevo vederlo un orco
in ascensore registriamo video per
segnare la truffa bene a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questa nuova truffa io
sono famigerati siete degli stronzi cosa
devo fare abbiamo fatto schiacciare i
tasti in tempo perché quel che cosa sto
vedendo signore
mate ka mate gioco è ma cos'è
magari solo agendo solo bravissimo cioè
è finito adesso sono fenomeno cioè che è
pazzesco salva video
non sa dire ho capito ma poi non se ne
sono accorti di tutto questo
mi hanno accolta con le mani in pasta
per fortuna l'altro il pizzo da mangiare
ciao gigi in diretta web accidenti
proprio ora che sta per fare un sacco di
soldi dove venire a rovinarci la truffa
se non fosse stato per tempo e il cane
impiccione si certi casi scooby doo hai
rovinato cyberwar il mio cyber war o sai
però come fanno guadagnare senza di te
siamo bravissimi squadra al piano sono
successe visto il tuo canale il mio
canale c'è una marea di messaggi
graziosa segnalazione sei una star
grazie non aver truffato i prescritti
per fare soldi
[Applauso]
grazie
serve ritrovare a molte persone
condivido se ad esempio devi fare
attenzione a quello che dice fai sapevo
di potermi fidare di te per risolvere
questo problema ora devo andare a casa
c'è già una sorpresa che ti aspetta i
file presenti infatti esce tutti cos'è e
come sei fortunato di arrivato un regalo
a parte mi hai regalato solo 4 milioni
di iscritti che per te sono niente poi
ci sia un eroe gioco raggi d'ispirazione
va bene mi sono tutti dell'eroe grazie
grazie amici ho fatto e spodestato il
truffa sono mister robot ci stanno
tracciando
prendo io a ballack tardi ma qualcosa
che sta facendo qua da tre giorni col st
barca in spiaggia che posso fare una
foto con una barca qualcuno ha
parcheggiato di merda e non sono stato
io con stile quello che vediamo nella
sua funzione
bellis qualcuno ha parcheggiato di merda
e udite udite non non sono stato io
mille like valente che sa fare centrali
ci mancano di sicuro della truffa
galattica ottimo lavoro fa vj grazie al
varo grazie al varo grazie gigi maccaro
cercherò di phillip high cos'è un poster
di clip
più di bari ha regalato un poster di più
di fi va bene che avete nick rivela
abbiamo vissuto smantellare ready
truffatore di stato etico grazie mille
youtube city ora è una città più giusta
non ti dimenticheremo mai tuoi amici pd
fa yemaya
quindi ogni volta che farò un video c'è
sempre ci deve sempre essere più di pai
che mi guarda bene adesso è il momento
di registrare qualcosa devo fare che non
vi siete e mezza ragazzi siamo alle
sports bar e devo prendere un pacco per
susy che non so però se sia del cassetto
equa top 10 f k you yeah sarà dove solo
entrare e uscire perfetto ecco qua ma
non mi ha preso lascia che il top 10 f k
che cazzo è scusata presto poi top10 fkd
moda non ho capito ma secondo voi aperta
sul sì sì perché l'orario di cena
piccante rehn le scrivo da susi o
vorrei prendere nel sito vorrei darti
aspetta il pacco non pensare male sarà
già l'altra volta un casinò in più mi
servirebbe che mi desse un po da
mangiare perché tengo fan quindi dammi
qualcosa un risultato questo mangiarono
qua adesso mangia
ma il tuo problema per fare grazie l'ho
mangiato in piedi un servizio di merda
però il vero era buono grazie a posto
vado a casa a fare video o un bel video
compiti poi dietro tipo registra video
potrebbe aver senso inizia a registrare
e saluti il canale ciao canale ti lasci
scappare un pò avrò hashtag fly
perché limitavo pd fa ieri anche quanto
priva incredibile chiedi agli iscritti
ma che cazzo sto facendo
sono bravissimo ho fatto anche più di
pai nel video cioè dare tanta roba edita
video allora puntiamo subito video di
ieri a due sono honey playstation a
questo qua è questo ma questo qual è il
video era la live gli impieghi bizzarro
su youtube lasciamo questo titolo è
bellissimo perché veramente per
curiosità voglio vedere cosa succede 100
like un video di merda va bene comunque
forse dico forse faccio in tempo ad
andare al municipio per la partenza lo
aspetta un attimo
municipio
dalle 8 alle 20 ok o quattro ore di
tempo non so se ci arrivo perché quel
tempo il problema ragazzi visto gioco ha
un solo problema il tempo va troppo
veloce perché non arrivò nei punti dove
deve arrivare in tempo meyer come il
problema perché gli iscritti sono sempre
così incazzati qual è il problema perché
i miei scritti sono sempre incazzosi
cosa fa che succede qua una macchia sica
strada e lo farò video signore mie nova
come mangia porco demonio questo quando
mangia lo riprende la macchina che sarà
incastrata nella m che bello municipio
ix municipio se dio vuole
prendo la patente però non ha voluto per
78 anni dovresti fare patente
la licenza costa 100 volete le valide
per un anno si siena
l'esame si tiene al porto ti stanno già
aspettando i tre tentativi ma cosa
davvero vini che
va beh devo fare ad un guida del
dobbiamo prender i birilli e bellissimo
a sucate tutti però un modo contro
birillo 15 faccio un video porca [ __ ]
esattamente come l'ho presa io ragua le
ho la patente grazie stronzo
a nokia me l'ha già data va bene niente
a posto è stato più facile del previsto
quanto facile perché la patente visto
posto e quindi ma adesso ve li fa pagare
i cosi bellissimo parte non sono anche
due sono di scooter
se io faccio dixie la zia ma io vorrei
sposarmi con qualcuno minchia tipo in
the sims 3 che se non la faccio un sacco
di blues di prendo adesso che sono
arrivato vai vai scooter l'ex viola mai
gratis
io pensavo con si pagasse nicchia
ragazzi mi ha cambiato mi ha svoltato la
vita ragazza roba piccante l'evento con
lo scooter così piccante reni andranno a
fare un'altra consegna che mi sembra
interessante anche se non so 3 apr prova
bene raga vi dice che avviene quando non
c'è via roma porco demonio ci ho messo
due bakwa questa città è piena di
incidenti ma sapete fare le sapete
vivere lontano da casa tardissimo
sticazzi però avrei un pacco da
consegnare a viar ma non so dove avere
buona notte e stato divertente quindi
ragazzi vedo concludo qua vale il
provvisorio tenteremo di rimorchiare in
questo bellissimo gioco perché comunque
c'è anche la fase di rimorchio tipo the
sims non potete perdere lo rassicuro già
piano si sta scaricando quindi
concludiamo col video spero che di
semplice ed iscritti al canale lasciato
bene mi piace e noi ci diamo come sempre
ad un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]